okay economic policy aside domestic
policy aside foreign policy aside
malignant narcissism aside we've been
following the outlandish and Behar bit
bizarre behavior of Donald Trump for a
couple of years now if you've seen some
of the interviews that I've done about
this topic you know that there are
numerous serious mental health
professionals in the United States who
have identified that Donald Trump's
mental state seems to be declining at a
moderate pace his speaking abilities his
ability to express himself dynamically
and articulately he was able to do this
20 years ago go back and look at
interviews he was able to do it even ten
years ago better than he is today that
ability has been notably declining for a
period of time now that exceeds his
presidency it even goes back to the
campaign a little bit some mental health
professionals we talked to you are
calling it a pre dementia State others
are calling it subclinical cognitive
decline that may not yet meet clinically
diagnoseable sort of levels some others
are saying no this is actually
clinically diagnoseable at this point or
there's kind of a mix here between a guy
who is just in his 70s now and not in
particularly good health
combined with personality disorders
however you want to sort of qualify it
or quantify it one of the signs of this
sort of behavior includes Trump circular
speech repeating the same words very
often without sort of being able to snap
out of the circle and make whatever
point he has in mind that he's trying to
make being unable to fully express
himself and actually carry through a
point from start to finish his my uncle
nuclear weapons a Wharton speech is an
example of that go back and look forward
on youtube if you don't remember that
one so what I have for you today is
really strange video that is only
raising even more concerns about this
this is new video from over the weekend
Donald Trump was trying to tell a story
I think about how former presidents
George W Bush and Barack Obama built
parts of a bad wall like a wall that's
not good
the Mexico border and then Trump became
oddly fixated on doors in the wall and
again it's just anyone's guess what he's
trying to say he seems unable to snap
out of it is trump putting the doors in
is he not are the doors good or bad
expensive or cheap it's not clear what
Trump is talking about and he seems
unable to even make a point you know
when you talk about previous
administration so we have a stretch
along the Rio Grande where and you
people know exactly where I'm particular
it's about 38 miles done by actually
both previous administrations it was
sort of done as a combination of one
going into the other and it's a wall not
a good looking wall it's a wall it's got
36 doors at at big doors very big doors
and they never put the doors on so it's
38 miles with 36 doors that you can
drive a truck through there's only one
problem they never put the doors on it
so we're putting the doors on it or even
better maybe not putting any doors I
said maybe you do it without the doors
because putting the doors on cause more
than the property is worth I'd rather
give the money for the property and just
say bye-bye your cell it to somebody on
the other side but I mean literally
putting the doors on course more money I
said what's the property worth on the
other side much less than the doors
these are doors with the hydraulic they
need hydraulic because they're so heavy
which is ridiculous in itself but so
that's the kind of thinking that went
into this so now we're filling up those
big those big gaping wounds in this wall
this is somebody who's in a fog I mean
he doesn't know what he's talking about
a wall with 36 big heavy doors with
hydraulics which is ridiculous in and of
itself and as he says the the wall the
doors weren't actually put in its 36
doors you can drive a truck through
but there aren't doors so he's putting
them in except maybe he's not and maybe
we give the money for the doors to
somebody else it's really important to
understand this is Trump off-the-cuff
okay I get that he's awkward with the
teleprompter but this is what happens
without one and it didn't get any better
during other parts of this speech they
say and this is our new statement the
system is full can't take you anymore
whether it's a sigh
whether it's anything you want it's
illegal immigration can't take you
anymore we can't take you our country is
full our area is full the sector is full
can't take you anymore sorry can't
happen so turn around that's the way it
is so I got another weird moment where
he gets into these repetition comas it's
not clear what he's saying the country's
full the area's full the sector is full
this is not normal communication for a
72 year old who is of sound mind I'm not
making fun of Trump i yet III think he's
a fool I think he is ignorant on almost
every single political issue I believe
he's an embarrassment to the United
States around the world this is not
about any of that this is about possible
cognitive decline that rises to the
level of a diagnosis condition period
it's not funny it's it's not something
that we should be making fun of it's
something that no country should have a
president who's cognitively declining
and not able to think straight and what
would be great is if we could put
partisanship aside for a second I don't
like his policies people on the right do
like his policies this has nothing to do
with policy I don't know what he's
talking about I don't think he knows
what he's talking about because he gets
into these cycles where he's repeating
the same words he can't stop he forgets
what point he's even trying to make and
it's not the behavior of somebody who is
fit to be President of the United States
and as we know because of the
uncontrollable leaks that come non-stop
out of this White House there are people
working closely with him who have the
exact same concerns let me know what you
think is going on I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman the show is on twitter at david
pakman show follow us there and there is
so much news from this weekend that I
will be getting to glad you're with us
today I have some just absolutely
delightful video to play for you today
which I really enjoyed watching I think
a lot of you are going to really enjoy
it
and it's video of Democratic congressman
ted Lieu playing Candace Owens is now
infamous Hitler wasn't actually that bad
comment
to her face off of his phone during a
congressional hearing and there are so
many stories here in so many angles that
I want to talk about but let me first
remind you who the players are
congressman ted Lieu of course a
Democratic congressman from California
Candis Owens is an unhinged irrational
Trump supporter who sort of came to
prominence over something that she
labeled blex it the idea of black people
exiting the Democratic Party which of
course isn't working well and has been a
wholesale failure since Republicans are
worse for black Americans than Democrats
even though I would argue that Democrats
also need to be doing more for black
Americans and black Americans aren't
just pawns of the Democratic Party they
simply recognize that they would be
worse off if Republicans got to decide
policy than Democrats so blex it has
been a complete and total failure but
regardless Candis Owens is super
well-funded
involved with Turning Point USA often
defended by Donald Trump's kids and by
other prominent right-wingers and
supposedly I was actually going to have
a debate with her the original date that
was set tentatively was well originally
it was pitched as possibly happening at
politican in October last October in Los
Angeles that didn't happen then a third
party that was organizing the debate
pitched march 18th as last March by the
way but this past a month ago March 18th
as a date and then we were told that her
camp is being a little bit more it's big
it's become a little more difficult to
actually finalize it then she blocked me
on Twitter and organizers are saying its
remaining difficult to finalize this
debate and I don't know what's going to
happen with it but that's Candace Owens
okay she said not long ago that Hitler
wanting to sort of do his thing in
Germany to bring his vision to Germany
would have been one thing and it would
have generally been okay but that the
mistake Hitler made was going globalist
which was the wrong use of the term
globalist anyway globalist means
something else but I think we understand
what what she meant so for some
harebrained Riis
that I can't even understand that
Candace Owens who recently made those
comments was invited to testify before
Congress on the topic of white
nationalism white nationalism now I can
think of no worse person to testify
about white nationalism to Congress then
perhaps I mean at her I don't even know
I'm having trouble thinking of who would
be a worse person to testify on this
issue before Congress but in any case
Candace Owens was there and Democratic
congressman ted Lieu played this Hitler
clip to her face and it was just
glorious I'm gonna play it for you and
he brilliantly points out why is Candace
Owens here after playing the clip he
then asks another woman who is
testifying from the anti-defamation
league full disclosure my brother works
for the anti-defamation league whether
that comment from Candace Owens that he
played was disturbing and if you check
out the look on Candace Owens's face as
Ted Lewis playing this she is furious
trying to contain herself and it is just
as good as I imagined it would be take a
look in congressional hearings the
minority party gets a select its own
witnesses and of all the people the
Republicans could have selected
they picked Candace Owens I don't know
miss Owens I'm not gonna characterize
her I'm gonna let her own words do the
talking I'm gonna play for you the first
30 seconds of a statement she made about
Adolf Hitler I think that it gets the
definition gets poisoned by leaders that
actually want globalism globalism is
what I look what I don't want so when
you think about whenever we say
nationalism the first thing people think
about in at least in America is Hitler
you know he was a National Socialist but
if Hitler just wanted to make Germany
great and have things run well okay fine
problem is is that he wanted he had
dreams outside of Germany he wanted to
globalize he wanted everybody to be
German everybody to be speaking German
er all right so my first question is to
miss Hirsch enough
miss Owen said quote if Hitler just
wanted to make
Germany great and a half things run well
okay fine the problem is that you wanted
here dreams outside of Germany so when
people try to legitimize Adolf Hitler
does that feed into white nationalist
ideology it does mr. Lew I know that
miss Owens distanced herself from those
comments later but we expressed great
concern over the original comments great
thank you
yeah if Hitler wanted to just do his Jew
killing stuff within Germany okay now
that's a plan but once he goes beyond
the borders then he's a globalist and
that's not okay now I I will I have no
reason not to tell you that Candace
Owens as was mentioned in that clip has
since distance herself distanced herself
from the horrible thing that she
previously said but then what she did in
this congressional hearing is play the
race card
she said that by ted Lieu playing only
that part of her comment about hitler
ted Lieu is assuming that black people
are stupid and won't look at the full
context of her comment which is insane
because ted Lieu playing this clip has
nothing to do with specifically
targeting black people who were watching
the hearing right understand what she's
doing she's playing the race card
she hates playing the race card or says
that people shouldn't play the race card
but she's playing it herself
ted Lieu plays a clip of her saying that
the problem with hitler was that he went
global that if he wanted to just do his
vision within germany that would be one
thing that would be okay and then she
says by playing that and not playing the
context you are showing that you think
black people are stupid and won't look
up or understand the full context the
hell is she talking about has nothing to
do with black people and this is
literally what is called playing the
race card
she and her side claim to be against it
and she is doing it here and i know that
there are people who are criticizing ted
Lieu i saw some comments yesterday got a
couple of tweets and a couple of emails
from people saying david this is ted
Lieu doing sensationalism porn
bringing this video in it's a setup it's
staged it's ridiculous and he should be
criticized for it no no the outrageous
thing is having someone like Candace
Owens who made the comment at hearings
about white nationalism
that's the disaster porn I actually
commend what ted Lieu did here other
lawmakers should do this okay when
Republicans or Democrats sometimes
Democrats bring in wacky people to
testify this isn't partisan when vile
disgusting people are brought in to
testify who have a history of violent
disgusting comments like this it should
be I don't want to say a requirement but
it should be common practice that
members of the panel's members of the
committees and subcommittees call them
out and say the witness that the other
side has brought here previously said
this and play it on your phone put up
one of those oversized huge quote board
cards that they do and if it's Democrats
do it I don't care okay this is beyond
partisanship for me
Republicans bring a lot of wacky people
to testify sometimes Democrats also
bring in horrible people to testify call
them out and don't let them get away
with this stuff and the people that are
upset about what ted Lieu did your
concern trolling okay I have very little
time for you at this point in time we
have increasingly with the advent of
Trumpets American politics with Trump
and his kids and wacky white
nationalists all over the place
controlling policy and feeling fomented
and reinvigorated by Trump's presidency
the problem is not that ted Lieu played
a clip during a congressional hearing
the problem is that people like Candis
Owens and groups like Turning Point USA
are getting a voice that they shouldn't
have the country is worse off for them
having this voice and I'm not saying
they shouldn't be allowed to speak this
isn't a censorship thing it they should
be seen for what they are and no serious
administration should say here's an idea
of who we want to invite to the White
House here's an idea from Republicans of
we want to bring in to testify about
white nationalism there are serious
people that can talk about these issues
white nationalists being reinvigorated
and coalesced and and catalyzed by the
donald trump presidency is a real issue
the anti-defamation league is aware of
it other groups that track hate are
aware of it the Southern Poverty Law
Center despite all of the trials and
tribulations of the Southern Poverty
Poverty Law Center they have been
following it
we don't need Candace Owens
congratulations to Ted Lou for doing
this I love it and I look forward to
hearing from you about it which you can
partially do by commenting on this story
on our Facebook page at facebook.com
slash David Pakman show I've met lots of
people in my life with
obsessive-compulsive disorder and one of
the things that they've all said when
they talk about their affliction is that
they can't really explain why they keep
doing the rituals that they keep doing
whether it's turning on a light switch
turning it on and off three times before
leaving the house or having to be the
last one to say bye during a phone call
there is an element of it that's beyond
even their explanation it's just sort of
a reflexive thing that they do or in the
case of OCD may be something that they
obsessively do would be a more
appropriate way to say it there's
something very similar going on with the
Republicans in the Senate and this
robert muller report they keep blocking
a resolution which would be non-binding
wouldn't even put a date certain as to
when the Moller report would have to be
released they keep trying to pass it
Democrats keep trying to pass it and
have passed it in the house and
Republicans now five times have blocked
it in the Senate and they either can't
or won't explain why it is that they're
blocking it they claim to be for
transparency they claim that the Moller
report totally clears the president they
claim that they're not worried about the
contents of the Moller report and yet
they have now for the fifth time blocked
the resolution to at some point release
the Moller report and when you ask them
why they don't even seem to know Mitch
McConnell has blocked this thing twice
at least already
says he wants to give William Bar time
bogus reasoning because the resolution
gives William bar time it doesn't put a
time date on when the report has to be
released a Republican Lindsey Graham
said he blocked the resolution because
he wants more information about Hillary
Clinton's emails I'm not joking that
that's the reason why which makes no
sense whatsoever and he actually said
quote I'm making a political point by
blocking it Rand Paul when asked why he
is opposed to the release of the Moller
report says he wants an investigation
into how this Russia probe even started
in the first place which again is not a
reason to block the release of the
report if you want an investigation into
how the Moller probe started which we
know by the way but let's pretend for a
second Rand Paul doesn't know that's a
reason to propose your own resolution
calling for that investigation if that's
what he wants it's not a reason to block
this resolution and once again I go back
to this question why not just play along
with this resolution it's non-binding it
doesn't put a specific timeline on when
the report has to be released
it says that things that would be
prohibited by law from being made public
have to be redacted so it doesn't
prohibit all redactions and there are a
few different reasons why we may be
seeing Republicans block this time and
time and time again the first is pretty
obvious which is the report actually is
hugely damaging to Donald Trump and they
want to protect Trump period pretty
simple explanation a possibility number
two they're worried that if redactions
are made without a legal basis in other
words if the report is released with a
bunch of redactions and some of those
redactions were made for political
reasons not for legal reasons those
could be subject to unredacted by
Democrats through a procedure that
exists to do that that's another
possibility
another real possibility in terms of
what Republicans are doing here is that
maybe there's stuff in the Moller report
because it is more than 400 pages or
around four
pages as we learned last week maybe
there's material in there that if it's
released closer to the 2020 election it
could be damaging for Republicans in
their reelection campaigns in the house
or in the Senate maybe they are exposed
in some way and what really doesn't sort
of close for me on this Pat is that
throughout the entire thing for two
years the same people who keep
professing how innocent they are are
actively working to prevent an
investigation that supposedly would find
them innocent they are working to
prevent the release of a report which
supposedly vindicates them I've never
seen people who are so innocent that are
working so hard to prevent the proof of
their innocence from getting out well I
think they certainly know that they're
not innocent and that this report won't
totally vindicate them
I mean they've had a couple weeks now to
workshop an answer that would be
suitable to the American public as to
why we can't release the Malheur report
and they've come up with zilch like you
know the classified information thing
that falls apart the Hillary's emails or
why we have to focus on the the oranges
or the oranges of investigation that
falls apart too they're left with
nothing here there's no reason to block
them all a report we we are very close
to the first deadline on this thing the
first deadline is actually tomorrow I
believe and I'll be traveling to a
conference in Las Vegas if something
breaks tomorrow on this Ben Dixon is
going to be here to tell you about it
otherwise I'll be back on Wednesday or
Thursday when will likely have news
about whether that first deadline for
the Muellers
Mullah reports release to Congress has
been met my prediction is it is not
going to be and if it is it will be just
a comically redacted version that is
going to immediately make Democrats say
this can't be the version that William
bar provides to us I think that this has
a lot of legs I think this is going to
continue being an issue for weeks if not
months and there are still no straight
answers from Republicans about what it
is that is going on here there are two
stories that came together last night in
this sort of explosion of incompetence
and also impotence when it comes to some
policy so on the one hand you
Donald Trump's constant turnover in his
cabinet his cabinet members high-level
staffers just really really high rate of
turnover sometimes Trump forcing people
out sometimes Trump people deciding they
can't work with Trump and that's been
one issue on the other hand you have the
immigration Fiasco which involves the
fake crisis at the border it includes
Trump's total inability to make good on
even a fraction of the immigration
promises that he made
I guess most comically the border wall
across the entire us-mexico border which
Mexico was going to pay for which no one
with any kind of common sense of
rationality believed even from the
get-go those have been sort of two
parallel stories but they came together
last night helped with Donald Trump's
homeland security secretary
Kirsten Nielsen resigning as Donald
Trump continues to say totally
unintelligible things about the wall and
immigration which I'm going to get to a
little bit later as Donald Trump
continued to call Kirsten Nielsen early
in the morning at home asking her to do
things that her best assessment was were
illegal Donald Trump now pushing her out
and the the the explanation we've gotten
so far is that her resignation was not
voluntary but that she didn't grovel or
ask to keep her job either she put out a
statement late afternoon early evening
yesterday saying in part quote I have
determined that it is the right time for
me to step aside I hope that the next
secretary will have the support of
Congress and the courts in fixing the
laws which have impeded our ability to
fully secure America's borders and which
have contributed to discord in our
nation's discourse the way it seems this
thing went down according to the New
York Times yesterday is that she had a
meeting with Donald Trump at the White
House and as far as she knew the meeting
really was to figure out a plan but
clearly it didn't go well
CNN saying she didn't resign willingly
but she also wasn't groveling to keep
her job as I mentioned so here's the
chaos that this is all sandwiched
between which you really need to
understand in order to get the
context in which all of this stuff is
happening Donald Trump nominated Ron
vide ello to run iced Immigration and
Customs Enforcement and then very
quickly withdrew the nomination because
he decided he wanted someone tougher
than Ron vide ello total chaos Trump
went on a completely unintelligible rant
about the number of doors that Obama and
Bush didn't put in some areas of border
wall which Trump maybe is going to put
in but maybe not I know that doesn't
make any sense but I'm gonna play the
video for you a little bit later Trump
as I mentioned has been calling Kirsten
Nielsen early in the mornings at home to
tell her to do aggressive things
including certain things that are
illegal like for example blocking or not
allowing requests for asylum at the
border which just it's just against the
law and Kirsten Nielsen as extreme and
outrageous and reactionary as she is
recognized that those requests would
violate the law if she actually did it
and it's important to note that normally
when the Department of Homeland Security
Secretary resigns the deputy DHS
secretary would take over except there's
no DHS deputy secretary so instead the
commissioner of Customs and Border
Protection is going to take over for now
complete and total disarray and adding
to this kind of comedy of errors and
surreal nature of this farce there are
reports that the person Trump is
thinking about of nominating to replace
Christine Nielsen is former Virginia
Attorney General Ken Cuccinelli who is
most well known for wanting to make oral
sex illegal in the state of Virginia
that's the guy that rumor has it Donald
Trump is considering nominating to
replace the Kirsten Neilson so this is
one of those which is worse the cure the
disease sort of situations because on
the one hand Pat Kirsten Nielsen is a
completely disgusting conservative
reactionary on immigration it's good
that she's out but Donald Trump wants to
put someone in who's even more
disgustingly reactionary and he may
actually get it and this is a pattern
we've seen before Pat we saw it with
Mike Pompeo replacing Rex Tillerson we
saw it with Jeff session
being replaced by William bar I mean
listen Jeff sessions is a horrible
racist ideologue but at least he
realized he had to recuse himself on
Russia Trump replaced them with a guy
who's part of the cover-up of the molar
reports so I don't know what's worse
again the cure of the disease yeah and
remember Kerstin Nielsen was perfectly
fine with going along with the policy
that ice would separate children from
their families she didn't protest then
she didn't announce the resignation
maybe Trump demanded something of her
that was even worse I mean that's what
this kind of suggests and I'd have to
imagine that her replacement is going to
be even worse than she was going along
with policy like that who knows yeah and
like I said we know what he requested he
was requesting that she as policy stop
accepting asylum requests at the border
which she felt and lawyers believe is
illegal and and against the law so
certainly was
as we mentioned asking for things that
are far worse that we know of and
potentially even more that we don't so
she was horrible more than likely will
be replaced with someone who comes in
and is just willing to do Trump's
bidding we've seen that with Mike Pompeo
we've seen it with others people leave
who are horrible but then they're
replaced with others who are completely
subjugated by Trump and willing to do
his dirty work even if it crosses the
ethical moral or sometimes even legal
lines so who were we going to see
ultimately replace Kristin Nielsen we
don't know but complete and total
disarray around the continuing Fiasco
that is the Trump immigration not even
policy it's like failed policy or policy
that doesn't actually come to be despite
Trump's best wishes or most sincere
wishes I absolutely love this clip that
I'm going to play for you next here I'm
going to play for you video of a 23 year
old absolutely crushing a Fox News
so-called reporter so hard that you can
visibly see the Fox host unsure what to
do or how to react he is reduced to
sputtering and repeating the same things
over and over again this happened a few
days ago but someone just sent it to me
yesterday
we've seen this type of thing happen
before one time I recall is when
right-wingers
steven crowder did a stunt where he goes
to college campuses and encourages
random people to quote change his mind
and this left-leaning sort of socialist
type sat down and just destroyed Crowder
and Crowder didn't know what what hidden
hit hit him he looked punch-drunk almost
this is very similar okay the topic here
is the green New Deal FoxNews sent this
mush brained reporter Todd Pierrot to
ask people how are we gonna pay for the
green New Deal and he happened to sit
down and talk to 23 year old Jack vandal
of in a diner in Missouri and vandala
started rattling off correct precise and
pithy rapid-fire responses and Pierrot
was visibly shaken from it able only to
repeat his same questions over and over
again time and time again and repeat
Vanda loves answers back to him let's
take a look at this just beautiful
backfire of the fox news on the street
sort of narrative crafting interview
that they like to do jack is an info
specialist and he really wants Howard
Schultz to talk about a climate change
specifically the green New Deal which is
support why do you support it yeah it's
really important we keep below two
degrees Celsius of average warming
otherwise the consequence is going to be
devastating how do we pay for yeah how
did we pay for World War two at the end
of the day when something is this
important our economy is gonna suffer if
we don't pay for it okay but you do
agree with the sentiment that this is as
big a deal climate change that is as
World War two yeah I mean for a little
over 40,000 Americans died in World War
two and climate change is killing a
hundred fifty thousand people per year
at least okay let's talk about the money
because that's a huge part of this how
are we going to pay for yeah so during
World War two for one thing the
government just pushed some of the cash
upfront and raised some tax on some
folks but at the end of the day it
stimulated the economy so much that
everyone benefited okay so to review you
are in favor of raising taxes in order
to support the green New Deal if that's
the optimal solution the economists sort
out I'll go with that
Oh quick get me some guy in a maggot to
talk about bringing back coal or
something like that this guy is off
script truly well done by 23 year old
jack van de la vie completely commend
him here and the funniest part about
this is that the answers he gives are
really really simple
we've got to take care of the planet and
stop ruining it and the question of
money is never a question when it's
about wars or weapons we have money it's
just a question of priorities and Todd
Perot is sort of out of his league here
he has nothing prepared
he can't even fall back on some weak and
flaccid oh but what about inflation sort
of thing and he just repeats so you're
okay raising taxes to pay for it and of
course at that point Vandellas got him
in his hand and this is not about the
specific provisions of the green new
deal or whether it's all doable in 8 10
or 12 years this is a bigger issue and
the issue is the discussion about how to
pay for it is a misleading discussion
and it's a hypocritical discussion it's
misleading because number one it doesn't
deal in reality with how government
spending works and number two it ignores
the negative externalities of not
dealing with our dirty energy usage and
then it's hypocritical because the right
only asks about how to pay for it when
it's something that they don't want when
it's wars or missiles or tax cuts for
the rich we just do it the same way that
we could do it with the green new deal
and when young people call in to the
show and ask me hey David how do I
better engage in arguments and debates
with people who disagree with me I talk
about well you've got to be prepared
it's good to understand the other side's
views as well as you do your own the
explanations don't have to be
complicated but they have to be real and
they have to work in this case
Vanda love was prepared todd Piro
was definitely not prepared and really
importantly Vanda love was not only
prepared with the what but with the how
to say it he knew that in this format
you need quick snappy pithy and concise
statements and he had him ready and lots
of people have the knowledge that Vanda
love has they know the facts they know
the truth about the green new deal but
when a fox reporter shoves a mic in your
face and gives you 50 seconds you aren't
always ready to express it so clearly
and concisely the way Vanda love did on
both counts substance and delivery Jack
Vanda love
crushed it and I congratulate him and
just absolutely a pleasure to watch the
last segment we talked quickly about
Kirsten Nilson being fire Stephen
Miller's cruelty being the point that's
what he dreams about being cruel at the
border and Donald Trump but we briefly
mentioned the illegal actions that the
president was asking border agents to
carry out we briefly alluded to it but I
want you to take a look at this video of
acting White House chief of staff Mick
Mulvaney as he makes it clear that the
president is going to break the law in
another way they knew they were they're
not going to get these these taxes they
know what the law is they know that one
of the fundamental principles of the IRS
is to protect the confidentiality of you
and me and everybody else who files
taxes they know that they know the terms
under law by which the IRS can give them
the documents but political political
hit job is not one of those reasons so
they know that it be clear you believe
Democrats will never see the president's
tax returns
oh no never no nor should they ok so
Mick Mulvaney has made it clear that the
president despite Congress asking for
the president's tax returns in a very
formal and a legal fashion that the
president will never turn over his tax
returns
now you can debate about what's going to
turn up is there anything in there the
substantive are the Democrats just
playing political games you all can
debate that as much as you want what's
important here is for us to realize that
we have a President of the United States
who's willing to look at the law and
simply say I'm going to ignore it the
the request that was made it was made
last week by the House Ways and Means
Committee Chairman Richard Neal he
formally requested it using he was
citing a an old old IRS code but it's
legal nonetheless which gives the
chairman of the House and Ways and Means
Committee the ability to request the IRS
turn over tax returns for basically
anybody now you can argue whether or not
you think that code is legal or
it's appropriate or whether it should be
overturned but rather it is legal and so
he's using the law to make a formal
request of the IRS and the IRS actually
has until tomorrow the 10th to respond
now this doesn't mean that Trump can't
challenge this Trump can challenge this
in court
Trump does have the ability to push back
against this but for Mick Mulvaney to go
out and simply say that they're never
gonna get it despite the fact that there
is an IRS code that allows the House
Ways and Means Committee Chairman to
request this tax return shows you just
how unlawful this administration really
is and quite frankly how giddily how
happily they are about being able to
just do whatever they want to do and the
belief that they are above the law
this is very clear and Attorney General
Holder former attorney General Holder
sees it much the same way he said on
yesterday via Twitter he said quote
really two questions in referring in
reference to Mick Mulvaney he said what
is he hiding and on exactly what basis
of the Trump administration going to
lawfully not disclose the tax returns in
response to a legitimate congressional
request this is a direct affront to the
rule of law serious precisely the case
right when you couple this with the
illegal when you when you couple the
fact that Trump is going to ignore of
the requests of Congress right Mick
Mulvaney the chief of staff right saying
that we're just going they're never
going to get his tax returns when you
couple that with the fact that Donald
Trump just last week was asking agents
at the border to directly break the law
then you understand that we have a
president who is lawless who believes
he's above the law and believes that all
of this infrastructure all of these all
of this bureaucracy everyone who who
works for the federal government works
for him and not for the laws of the land
and that is the perfect combination to
see not only atrocities but to see the
overturning to see the undermining of
our nation in a way that we haven't seen
a long time that we in a way that we've
never seen
you know yeah yeah I mean of course the
civil war comes to mind however this is
this is coming directly from the
president of the United States and and
while a lot of this can be dismissed as
people would want to dismiss this as
hyperbole it's the little things man it
really is the little things that if
Donald Trump was able to get these
border agents to break the law in this
manner right if he's able to look at
Congress and say I'm simply going to
ignore you those things first of all
they're not little but even if you
disregard them as being you know
insignificant then they simply you
cannot deny the fact that they add up to
the possibility of us undermining our
government in a way that we've never
seen right when you have armed forces so
to speak who are willing to ignore the
law of the land and simply do what the
president says that is a recipe for
disaster now I want to read a quote
here's a couple of quotes from CNN so
that you can get the full breadth and
depth of what the president was asking
at the border and then I want you to
compound that I want you to sit that
side-by-side juxtapose that to what the
president is saying through Mick
Mulvaney in terms of I'm just going to
ignore the Congress the president told
Agence agents via CNN not to let
migrants in quote last Friday the
president visited California where he
said we're full our systems full our
countries full you can't come in our
country is full why what can you do we
can't handle anymore
our country is fool can't come in I'm
sorry it's very simple behind the scenes
two sources told CNN the president told
border agents not to let migrants in
tell them we don't have the capacity he
said if judges gives you trouble say
sorry judge I can't do it we don't have
the room after the president left the
room agents sought further advice from
their leaders who told them that they
were not giving them the direction and
if they did what the president said they
would take on personal liability you
have to follow the law they were told
they
fascinating I mean look at the mindset
of the President of the United States he
literally told them to go to a judge if
you get in trouble I want you to break
the law and if you get in trouble with
the judge tell the judge I said that
we're falling we can't come in it it's
mind-boggling that that this is okay
to a certain percentage of the
electorate it doesn't blow me away
anymore that this is what Donald Trump
is it does not blow me away that this is
where we've gotten to in this country
what blows me away is how we got here
and the fact that the people who support
it Donald Trump can look at this and say
that it's okay you know what they can
look at this and say that this is okay
because they are they are they're loyal
to Donald Trump and not the United
States of America this is a good place
as any there's a clip of a documentary
of Steven not Steven Miller but uh Steve
Benning and Steve Bannon is at a rally
and there's a lady who stands up in the
crowd and she says she essentially says
no she presides says that she never
thought she would want a dictator but if
she did if America did have a dictator
she would want it to be Trump listening
can you hand the mic to the back yes
ma'am
never in my life did I say one let's get
one more question can you hand the mic
to the one in the back yes ma'am never
in my life did I think I would like to
see agitator but if there's gonna be one
I want it to be Trump
it's unbelievable and it shows you the
power of the cult of personality it does
it shows you how tenuous American
democracy is in general right how how
how democracy can lean towards a
strongman it can lean towards dictators
it leans toward hyper partisanship which
pushes people in the corner so far and
so wide that they will swear allegiance
even to the point of undermining the
nation right they will swear allegiance
to a dictator they will swear allegiance
to their political figure it just shows
you how tenuous and how just how much
democracy can hang on by a thread
especially when you have a segment of
the population who can be so easily
driven into this fury that they're
willing to turn over all legality all
since their rights in the Constitution
over to a person like Donald Trump or
over to anybody period
it's absolutely asinine I'm trying to
I'm trying to explain it and explain it
without being like you know so bombastic
about it but this is this is madness and
you have a segment of our of our
population who still today can look at
the president telling Border Patrol
agents to break the law who could look
at Congress and say I don't care what
you say I'm gonna do what I want to do
and then not only are they not offended
by this but they sit back and say yeah
that's our dude that's our guy that's
exactly the kind of leader we want in
fact if we went if we're gonna have a
dictator we would want it to be Donald
Trump yeah man listen I'm going to
participate in the Democratic primaries
but whoever wins the primaries we better
get out there and vote all of these
people out of power because if we keep
empowering people like Donald Trump you
see the madness that is driving his
supporters and they don't care how far
he goes there is no limit we used to
think that he could get it well actually
I'm sorry it is actually true what they
said he can shoot somebody on Fifth
Avenue in New York City and his
supporters that thirty some odd percent
a huge
percentage of the voting electorate
still will support him